it looks like he's on an all-inclusive
holiday somewhere it could be going to
like an under ATMs night night out
hi I'm Delhi and I'm gonna be looking at
some of football's best and worst
fashion moments for ideas Harry Kane
looks like he's on the cruise y'all I
love Scott I just had one of these
partners as well it was in Berkeley and
I used to wear it so it must have been
and he definitely wouldn't wear it now
mainly because it's not like here he
wears nice around what bowl is up yeah
everything about his pictures are on
fine the haircut he sure looks all right
yeah I think these mirror selfies are
really in back in a day and then my left
and stuff and that crazy hairdo
hopefully he's moved on from this now so
this one is all Shaka for last long
yeah it's not great I think it's a Gucci
tracksuit perhaps nice that's really
nice we hope you got that track suit for
free
Ilana
it looks like he's on an all-inclusive
holiday somewhere I'm gonna say Tenerife
or something like that or he could be
going into like he's kind of bets as
though he could be going so I could
under English night night out but we've
all made these mistakes back in the day
yeah I probably would have made this
mistake because I think I've done
something similar
I hope we're gonna do really well I
don't think anyone can say you know it's
gonna anything can happen
we see last year of Iceland in blob two
years ago of Iceland in the universe we
can't you know it has to be focused in
every game and we feel confident with a
really strong team with managers yeah
we're excited we have possible I can see
what he's going for
pretty sure it's all Rico in just want a
bit over the top of it but I think you
have to looks like he should be on
Assassin's Creed or something like that
here's the best one of England's
greatest fashion people ever already
comment on Beck's can I is a legend this
is like what the question was back in
the day of thing but as I'm done on the
show and after the woolly hat he must
have been having a bad hair day family
yeah it's very in-your-face and he looks
like like the nineties hip-hop with like
the Hat on the side a little bit aside a
little bit I don't know if it's meant to
be like that
fancy dress everyone knows it's like
soon you step on them over their white
lines you know friendships and I saw out
the window
you're there to win sir this is the best
one this is me so I was actually going I
think I was going to like Oceana
I'm very English night or something like
that well I some party thing with my
friends I had yellow sunglasses on him
my friend had blue and one had pink and
yellow chemicals on his own this outfit
this is a 10 straight 10 just as strong
so that was some of footballers best and
worst fashion throughout the years